hey everyone I have a little welcome my
channel I'm currently live-streaming the
online beta for Red Dead or read it
online and as always start off with a
male character okay all bad so far I
don't like I don't like that okay either
way oh no the teeth put them away pretty
[ __ ] teeth away stop I hate it I'll
go and get my picture took well hello
there what's this fancy device you have
can you buy new teeth
cuz I'm 100% gonna do that [ __ ] they've
already got me hooked on the grind the
teeth is so bad I'm already committed
give me those gold nugs yep I've already
played this game I don't need the
tutorial we good but thank you
I appreciate it I guess we just gotta
have faith Arthur he looks like if Daryl
did a lot of drugs and then became like
a mobster he's what he looks like
like I still think I did pretty well all
things considered but it's not good
well you really just dropped me in
between two horses didn't you well oh I
showed his hat off really all right
ah I didn't mean to do that I see horses
still have a mind of their own run in
trees killing people it's fine thanks
Eagle vision
I mean Eagle Eye definitely not at all
taken from Assassin's Creed I don't know
what you're talking about
No
get down the hill all right yep all
right you didn't need to jump that
coulda just walked around it's fine well
get a clay Davies ooh
matchmaking it's finally happening I
really would have thought it would have
started like this but it didn't and
that's fine someone come help me all
right cool yes oh I have to buy even
that you're gonna make me buy a color
change okay the it's fine you know what
never mind it's fine and it's also a bit
shady that it's making me go through all
of this stuff it's like hey you want to
see all the stuff you can't buy hey bro
hey what's up how you doing
it's we had to people are just gonna
come up and stare at me is that sort of
what we all do here we just stand around
and look at each other a bit okay well
I'm uncomfortable here each other but
not you in the game what did when do you
stream sniped me or something he stream
snipe me no way I keep hitting friendly
stream snipers us Scotty Hawkeye oh you
were the pretty girl with the nice vest
oh no I it's that I couldn't invite into
a posse I said [ __ ] hold up dick move
did this phone did this did this game
just tell me that that I have to pay a
daily stable fee you're gonna charge me
every single day for nothing that's
shitty that's not good yes thank you
because apparently I have to pay goddamn
horse taxes ever
so hey [ __ ]
I found it so that's fine
right
just gonna loot everyone oh this one
light
would everyone because this games trying
to steal my money and I want to make
sure that I get my own money okay so I
little the dead bodies and the people
that I kill it's fine all right got this
caught getting in caught delivering
caught - Wallace station so on a
countdown timer
well surely I'll make it there the
countdown timer implies to me if I know
anything about game design that oh come
on areum that mall people for me to
shoot I'm gonna show up but it's fine
we'll get through rival players can
attack the cot cool glad I'm doing this
by myself because my mic yeah headset is
not working [ __ ]
no no oh no I'm so sorry I didn't mean
to do that
I didn't mean to well that wouldn't
watch through me so that's convenient
let's just keep going
all right it's time to do some racists
oh not racist it's definitely didn't
mean to say that meant race different
things hey hey that was really rude man
combat enabled
nobody shoot can we all just not shoot
it'd be tops if we didn't like I would
very much like to not die well I'm out
in front of course I'm gonna get [ __ ]
what even happened
I don't really what happened what
happened man that was odd to follow and
now it's just black what hey for the
record Jesse I wouldn't punch him on my
face I wouldn't do it I'm gonna I'm
gonna give it a like hey guy
the kids love that I see you say whom
screwed oh man gaming and I'm looking at
you can you get on my horse well you
didn't need to do that that was rude
I mean now it says here you're hostile
you didn't need to see sorry it's okay
but it was pretty rude of you
hey hey stop why do you keep kicking me
oh my holy [ __ ]
I will ban you from miksa scoot a man
gaming okay I know I'm pretty sure
you're a mod but I will ban you what
just happened oh okay cool that's fun I
don't really mind
it's fine you you you just gonna break
me out all right thanks
I guess I was just looking at my menu
hey I appreciate it later
oh what a stupid interaction the
Internet's so dumb
why don't shoot me we just had a nice
bond I personally like to make friends
by hog-tying them I feel like Logan
blade is also someone who is stream
sniping me I'm not gonna fight you back
I don't care do what you will so let's
take a look at clothing sure so that's
19 full gold bars right now I've been
playing for two hours and I have well
not quite two hours I have 0.24 that
would take me a long [ __ ] time oh
yeah this would take a really long time
I have $15 a nice vest just a simple
vest surely couldn't cost that much to
go boss that's a lot more reasonable
it's locked to rank 9 sorry it was an
accident but I'm still sorry about it
this is my bad I didn't mean to do what
the [ __ ] was that what do you know you
have a deal
well [ __ ] away you get that deal will
you get that can I have it well there's
a rabbit I'll take it so that's how we
hunt rabbits ladies and gentle ok are
you following me do you want me to
follow you is that what you're implying
I'm gonna follow you then let's go ok
let's go where are we going
where we drop them boys you can lead me
somewhere let's go no no not this [ __ ]
again why do you keep doing this get up
and [ __ ] off come on yeah let's do it
take me to animals
all right I see that do
I should just let you bleed out now I
feel bad why is the music so intense
does it think these people are trying to
kill me
it's Posse who follows me around the map
I don't know it's good let's go let's
roll I'm ready I will follow you I don't
know which one you are yo Scotty hole
guy let's [ __ ] go
such a weird way to experience playing a
game is just having an escort
alright don't sass me my horses stamina
is very low okay we haven't bonded
I've known this horse for like two hours
he's kind of a [ __ ] yeah just like this
it's just like I had you know a butcher
stranges on mute you started following
him around hey bud got deer for ya okay
alright that just happens today yeah
take it how much cash you gonna give me
for it 280
alright not great it was a bad pelt
because they don't have a bow and arrow
speaking of which I'm gonna try and buy
a bow and arrow see if I can afford that
please let me be able to afford above
not even not even [ __ ] close not even
remotely close to being able to get a
bow that's so far away
oh very grindy is my hot take hey what's
up hi thanks for all the ways I really
appreciate it
are you gonna hog-tie me again you put
that goddamn rope down lady thank you
Jesus you guys just keep assaulting me
it's like having friends who
occasionally tackle you and then home
tell you and then apologize and take you
to a butcher
hmm Wow Wow
she just floating away it was like a
tack oh I didn't mean to I didn't mean
to do that that was an accident
what's happening
I need a shower look how daddy he is Oh
Carol you've been through some rough
times things are not going great for you
yeah hi okay I'll wave so [ __ ] needy
Jesus sorry I'm sorry just inherently
very mean oh cool all right that's how
you want to play me that's how you want
end stream Wow all right you know what
I'm out
Logan blade was really [ __ ] rude